Shazaam was directed by David F Sandberg
and is about a young boy named Billy
Batson he's a foster kid he's very
streetwise he's had a tough life and
when he has an encounter with a magical
wizard he gains the ability to transform
into an adult superhero when he says the
word Shazam I was looking forward this
movie for a few reasons for one the DC
EU has been really great lately
I loved Wonder Woman I really liked
Aquaman and I also am a big fan of David
F Sandberg who directed lights out and
Annabel creation I like what he's done
with a horror genre so I was excited to
see what he could do in a superhero film
and I'm also a fan of the 1988 film big
starring Tom Hanks and this looked like
a superhero version of that and so
naturally that enticed me and Shazam is
a really good time it's a very funny
movie it's it's much more of a comedy
than I expected it to be actually
because I'm not like super well-versed
with the character and with the
backstory but I knew enough going in
plus the trailers gave me the obvious
vibe that this was a very light-hearted
film that didn't take itself too
seriously
so it's really coming out of the perfect
time in our admittedly oversaturated
superhero market with endgame coming out
which is bound to be a very serious film
it's nice to have a movie that you can
sit back and just laugh and have a good
time watching Zachary Levi is fantastic
as the adult version of Billy Batson he
really embodied the spirit of a child
that's never had anything good happened
to him in his entire life who suddenly
has this amazing experience and
opportunity to accomplish things that he
never expected he'd be able to do before
and all of the scenes with Zachary Levi
are easily the best parts of the film
he's excellent in the film as is Jack
Dillon grazier who plays Freddie Freeman
his roommate at a foster home he
provides a lot of the comedy in the film
and where this could be a major risk
because he is a younger actor and so
much of him being so loud and so
boisterous that could get annoying
gratefully it doesn't I think they
struck a really good balance with the
interplay between those characters but
let's talk about that foster home for a
second because for me that's the heart
and soul of the movie and that's
probably my favorite aspect of the movie
the parents were excellent namely Cooper
Andrews who felt like he was the warmest
soul on the planet he was just so
energetic and so likeable Billy hasn't
had a easy
time in life he got separated from his
mom when he was young and never found
her again and now he's older and he's
still looking for her he's gone from
foster home to foster home in an early
scene we learned that he's searching for
her in a very complex and convoluted way
that gets him in trouble with the law
that could be just because he's a stupid
kid and he's making dumb choices or
because the writers wanted an
entertaining scene versus a more normal
way of searching for someone in our
modern day but nevertheless he ends up
at this foster home with a bunch of
other kids and that right there is the
best aspect of the movie I think that's
the emotional heart and soul of the
movie and most of those sequences I
thought were handled really well and
that added something to the film that I
think if it wasn't there
the rest of the movie would not be
nearly as impactful as it is this is
definitely taking a more old-school
approach with superhero films it feels
more like the type of movie that may
have come out in the 70s or early 80s
after Christopher Reeves excellent first
Superman film from Richard Donner it
feels more akin to that spirits there's
a sense of buoyancy to the movie where
it just feels like it's very light and
you could use the word disposable and
and some might use that word but I don't
think in the case of Shazam that's
necessarily an insult it just feels like
a breath of fresh air amongst a lot of
really heavy superhero films that we've
been experiencing lately I do have
issues with the movie though and most of
them surround Mark Strong villain
Satya sivanna this is someone who does
have a backstory they set him up fairly
well but then there's this huge gap
between when we last saw him and when we
see him now and so much has happened to
him during this period and were expected
to basically believe that from childhood
to now he has had the exact same grudge
from the exact same thing and has spent
his entire life being bitter about it
and his introduction as an adult is in
this facility where they're doing
research about this phenomena that's
spreading people are talking about this
this magical wizardry thing that they're
all experiencing and he's trying to
understand what's happening so that he
can hopefully experience it too and it
is one of the most hokey scenes
that I have laid eyes on in a superhero
movie recently now a lot of the movie is
very cheesy purposely and so it is
entirely possible that they were
genuinely going for camp if that's what
they were doing they succeeded but the
fact that it's a little unclear and
especially the musical score I think is
an issue here because the music tells us
in scenes like this that it's supposed
to be a serious moment rather than
letting us ease in to what really is a
very campy scene with scientists looking
over these like videos of people saying
they encountered a wizard and it's
like this is camp the musical score
didn't always let us know that and it
kind of messed with the tone because we
also have scenes where Billy Batson is
looking for his mom and it's sad and you
feel bad for him the tonal shifts
between drama and extreme comedy don't
always work in this film some of this
can be forgiven though because in many
ways the film is very self-aware and
very satirical of the superhero genre
and you can even look at that scene I
just mentioned and say they're poking
fun of the superhero genre but again the
way it's filmed the musical score it's
it's not as clear I think as it could be
you know it almost feels like they
really mean those scenes but there are
other scenes that are just hilarious
there's a great scene won't spoil it
involving two characters that are very
far away and it was funny but the film
is so knowingly self-aware of what it is
to the point where there's even a direct
reference to big in the movie and I feel
like when you have scenes like that
thrown in with some of these more campy
scenes that didn't work for me and
admittedly a very weak villain I thought
the overall movie we got is saved by
Zachary Levi's charismatic performance
as well as Jack Dillon grazier and a
great foster home story that really
gives the movie an emotional weight that
it would not have had without it I'm
gonna give Shazam a B guys thank you so
much as always for watching look forward
to more reviews very soon and if you
like this you can click right here and
get stuck
[Music]